in the lobby of Ramsey solutions I love
these a church debt-free scream pastor
larry is with us and Phil welcome guys
glad to have you guys it's great to be
here already here honor to have you you
guys are from where what city Jasper
Indiana Jasper Indiana and the church
that has become debt-free is called
named what Shiloh united methodist
church very cool very cool where's
Jasper exactly i can't get that in my
head it's about an hour south of
Bloomington Indiana okay okay very cool
good very neat I love it so tell me the
story Phil or our pastor larry one of
you tell me what happened here in the
whole process I'll start the story and
Phil can fill in the blanks the in 2002
are two thousand to the church started
his third building project and build a
family life center at the end of two
thousand to the records show that it was
2.3 million and debt at that point I
came into the picture in July first 2013
at that point they had reduced it down
to seven hundred thirty-two thousand
dollars okay 1998 I heard you for the
first time on the radio and Owensboro
Kentucky and my wife and I have been
debt free ever since oh when I was told
I was being appointed to a church that
had seven hundred thirty-two thousand
dollars in debt scared me to death and
so as I got into the setting and then to
the situation we began to talk about you
know what we could do to get out of it I
suggested that we do and plan a miracle
Sunday and a miracle sunday is a sunday
that is picked in the future as a date
to have the debts paid off by and so in
the spring of 2014 we contacted the
Bishop of the Indiana united methodist
church bishop coiner and he had december
6 2015 available so we scheduled that we
were going to make it a big celebration
and a wonderful day lots of partying had
a
meal scheduled and all that kind of
thing and so then the goal was to have
it paid off and on we sent a letter out
sep tember 15 2014 at that point we owed
575 thousand dollars or just short of
that and then 365 days later on sep
tember 15 2015 we cut the check for the
final payment re months early yes yeah
wow yeah wow we missed our goal we all
hate it when that happens and we also
overshot and so now we have money in our
capital improvement that's awful to have
savings yeah it's tough awful to be able
to do ministry in the market and I have
to borrow money to do it that's just he
says sarcastic so basically the whole
journey of 730 2000s about three years
long yes okay and Phil what was your
part in this whole thing what I've been
doing is I've been teaching the FPU
class probably since 2010 oh wow yeah so
we had probably a hundred people go
through FPU and not only from within the
church we've had people from outside the
church so it's been a great ministry to
the community absolutely right very and
then we've also said we just finished
the second time the generation change
for our youth and we had about 11 or 12
kids finish that up including my
daughter which I really proud of her for
that I love it so how many folks in your
old congregation about 300 worshippers
on Sunday morning I'll so you've had
almost everybody go through it for you
then as well sounds like yeah I mean a
hundred family units would be that a
bunch yeah that's that's pretty cool so
when you to really join hands I mean an
FPU coordinator that's on fire for the
whole thing and pastor who's been
through it p you in another place and
hates debt this is a perfect perfect
union right here to get rid of some debt
and there were a lot of people in the
church they caught the vision and we're
excited and wanted to see the debt
disappear so it wasn't just me it wasn't
just feel it wasn't even our committee
we a committee was put together two
years before I arrived it was called
mission possible but it was in the midst
of a pastoral change and so not a lot
happened and they couldn't they didn't
get a lot of traction until after we
started talking about the miracle Sunday
and moving forward that's fun well you
set a vision is what you did there's a
lot of fun very well done well and
somewhere there is a mr. Wesley that's
happy right now I'm hoping yeah because
he you know as you know he hated that
and I had a lot of writing about money
may go you can give all you can save all
you can one of my favorite Wesley quotes
on money anyway and so yeah and very
very interesting well congratulations
you guys and now the church's boys to
just do ministry all the all the tithes
and offerings are coming in all you can
all you should tell people now there's
sixty six thousand dollars in the budget
now that wasn't there before it was
fifty five hundred dollars a month paid
out an interest in principle every month
on that debt that now can go to help
people instead of LIHEAP us on bank open
and ministry that's right awesome that's
that's just the way it should be that's
exactly the way it should be well
congratulations you two and
congratulations to shiloh united
methodist church that's a lot of fun so
I I'll have to catch you at the break
pastor you two got to see this my
grandmother's grandfather I remember how
many great-greats they were was a
circuit riding United Methodist /
brethren before the split back in the
Civil War days was fought in the Civil
War from Indiana and ended up riding
south and carried a Bible on the back of
an old mule and I was a circuit riding
Methodist rather United Brethren
preacher and I've got the Bible from the
1800s I'll show it to you at the break
so be great so it's near and dear to my
heart that a shallow United Methodist
Church Jasper Indiana baby seven hundred
and thirty-two thousand dollars paid off
in three years and we got video and
audio of the whole congregation doing
their debt free scream fire it up guys
three two one
ah as it should be I love it I love it I
love it congratulations you guys very
well done and Phil thank you for leading
the class all these years and being
being diligent to do that a lot of
families set free with that thank you
sir god bless very neat very neat that's
how it's done right there hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that your broke friends think
you've lost your mind